guten morgen paul ronzheimer moral was
hast du gestern noch für information
erhalten was wir insgesamt an
informationen erhalten haben als politik
ressort alle kollegen zusammen ist das
was dort passiert ist zwischen der union
und den grünen in dem treffen es hat ein
paar stunden gedauert aber dann konnten
wir enthüllen welche themen die dort
besprochen wurden insbesondere
migration war ein großes thema ein
großes thema war die eu finanzen der
stabilitätspakt und es war klar was wir
aus diesem gespräch gehört haben dass
die grünen richtung ampel offenbar geht
und danach gab es den schock danach als
wir das enthüllt haben gab es
riesenwellen riesen debatten es gab
tweets es gab debatten darüber was da
passiert ist und es hat dann am ende
dazu geführt dass es wie am tag zuvor
zum großen knall geführt hat wir sehen
hier die bilder gerade symbolische
geradezu armin laschet im regen die
union steht im regen paul unserer
enthüllung sorgen für große aufregung
nicht nur verbanden den politikern die
süddeutsche zeitung schreibt zitat es
könnte gut sein dass es dereinst einmal
heißen wird dass das der moment war in
dem sich entschieden hat dass
deutschland von einer ampel und nicht
von einer jamaika koalition regiert wird
und auch in den nachrichten von ard und
zdf war es das top thema gestern abend
wir schauen mal kurz rein
nun werden es stimmt dass heute abend
erneut eine zeitung wesentliche punkte
des vertraulichen gesprächs durch
gestochen wurden dann muss ich ehrlich
sagen war das der todesstoß für
sondierungsgespräche der union auch
diesmal übrigens kein stillschweigen
aller beteiligten nach dem treffen
wieder erfuhr die bild einzelheiten die
grünen reagieren wie zuvor die fdp
genervt
ich gehe davon aus dass jamaika
zumindest jetzt nicht kommen wird ich
glaube nicht dass es da mit unseren
enthüllungen zu tun hat ich glaube dass
am ende die inhaltliche
auseinandersetzung war das chaos in der
union und ich glaube dass fdp und grüne
jetzt einen grund suchen um zu sagen wir
gehen richtung ampel und dafür ist
natürlich leicht zu sagen bild hat das
enthüllt bild hat dieses enthüllt die
reden öffentlich so zu sagen und dann
gehen wir da raus ich glaube nicht dass
am ende so zu sagen dass das
entscheidende war sondern dass es der
letzte stein möglicherweise wir können
auch mal auf die tweets schauen das war
gerade mich ja keiner gesetze der grünen
der gesagt hat es nervt und so einen
tweet haben wir schon mal gesehen aus
zwei liest und hört man nichts aus
zweien werden angebliche
gesprächsinhalte an die medien
durchgestochen und einen solchen tweet
am wer schon mal gesehen paul wir sind
noch mehrere aber wir haben einen ganz
ähnlichen wie denen der grünen schon mal
gesehen ja von johannes vogel den
fdp-vize man wundert sich so ein wenig
warum sich grüne und fdp auf einmal so
gut verstehen die haben sich zueinander
gefunden und die wissen sie entscheiden
am ende wer kanzler wird sie hätten
entscheiden können was bei jamaika
passiert und sie können entscheiden was
bei der ampel passiert deswegen sie
rotten sich mehr oder weniger zusammen
der fdp-vize blutig hofer hat etwas
getwittert es ist sozusagen eine debatte
dort entstanden die dafür sorgt dass am
ende diese citrus koalition da
entscheidet wer kanzler in deutschland
und man wundert sich auch ein bisschen
normalerweise werden müssen blogger
gefeiert auch von den politikern und
hier nervt ist einfach nur wieso ist das
so es nervt natürlich diejenigen die
dort verhandeln und man versucht das
jetzt so auszulegen als da ist was
wahnsinnig besonderes dass da etwas
rauskommt ist natürlich nicht wir bei
bild enthüllen täglich erhöhen
wöchentlich all das was in den
inhaltlichen gesprächen passiert wir
haben in der mpk jedes mal all das
enthüllt was dort gesprochen wurde also
für uns bei bild nichts besonderes aber
dort in den koalition möchte man sich
jetzt gegenseitig die schuld zuschieben
um dann zu sagen es lag an dem oder den
die frage diese man sicher immer stellen
müssten wenn etwas durchgestochen will
paul ist wem nützt es cui bono wem
nützt es ich glaube wir haben ganz ganz
viele quellen unsere kolleginnen und
kollegen die für bild arbeiten sind
überall dort wo etwas passiert von daher
würde ich auch gar nicht darauf setzen
dass es ein maulwurf wache sondern
möglicherweise viele viele und ich
glaube es geht am ende für uns wie du es
schon am anfang gesagt dass um
transparenz da wir entschieden wie
deutschland regiert wird da wird am ende
entschieden wer wird kanzler und wir bei
bild haben da etwas sozusagen zu zu
recherchieren was dort genau passiert
der entscheidende punkt ist ja bei
diesem ersten verhandlungen so ist es
jedenfalls offiziell ausgerufen worden
wir tasten uns mal ab was die inhalte
angeht da gibt es schnittmengen aber vor
allem sollte ja vertrauen gebildet
werden nur dieses
vertrauensbildung hat ja offenbar
funktioniert zwischen den grünen und der
fdp zum teil auch mit der spd da ist
nichts durchgesickert bei der cdu hat
aber nicht geklappt ich glaube natürlich
ist die union in einer besonderen lage
es gibt viel kritik an armin laschet es
gibt leute die sich aufstellen und sagen
ich will parteichef werden ich will
fraktionschef werden ich möchte die
zukunft dieser partei oder der union
bestimmen und das bedeutete am ende auch
immer kampf und krampf und das bedeutet
dann auch das vielleicht der eine etwas
will was der andere nicht möchte pauli
jetzt haben die grünen um 10 uhr ein
statement angekündigt was erwartest du
es ist damit vorbei mit dem
wunderschönen flug nach jamaika ich gehe
davon aus dass die grünen heute
zumindest eine richtung bekanntgeben
dass sie sagen werden wir wollen die
ampel verhandeln ich glaube es bleibt
ihnen gar nichts anderes übrig die basis
bei den grünen die will die ampel
ohnehin das viel spannendere passiert
bei der fdp wie werden die begründen was
sie tun erstaunlich ist aber dass es so
schnell geht die die digitale konferenz
der grünen beginnt um 9 und um 10 uhr
soll es schon presse statement geben da
kann man ja nicht in einer stunde die
ganze zukunft durch diskutieren naja es
gibt ja auch nicht darum die ganze
zukunft durch zu diskutieren ich glaube
was man noch mal erklären muss ist es
geht ja darum jetzt in
koalitionsverhandlungen zu gehen und zu
sagen wir verhandeln das was dort
passiert es geht ja nicht darum zu
beschließen wir machen die koalition
aber glaubst du dass wenn es so schnell
geht das die meinungsbildung bereits
abgeschlossen ist bei den grünen ich
gehe davon aus dass die meinungsbildung
bei den grünen abgeschlossen ist das
natürlich auch das was in den letzten
tagen passiert ist das bild enthüllt hat
dazu geführt hat dass bei den grünen ist
eine klare richtung geht und die geht
richtung ampel
[Musik]